you're not going to be successful in
life if you become a slave of these
Technologies a slave of these machines
now the question is how does one Take
Back Control and make these machines
into your slaves instead of the other
way around there's basically three
things that you can do strategy number
one is to Fight Fire with Fire I've been
using an extension for many many years
now called news feed Eradicator and it
completely eliminates the news feed from
my Facebook page there are apps like
this for Instagram Twitter and even
YouTube strategy number two is to
manipulate your physical environment I
found that working at home is near
impossible because that's where I tend
to relax so what I've done instead is
manipulate my physical environment by
going outside and working in random
cafes and finally strategy number three
training yourself like a dog and a great
way to do this is to work for a bit and
then purposely reward yourself for a
short period of time sort of like how
you would give a dog a treat after he
does a trick